[Music]
I've taught some cases on culture. So, that gives me a
little bit of credibility I hope on that score. But on the
venture piece, actually last year I took a leave to run a
small startup in the fitness industry. So, hopefully now I
have more credibility on the entrepreneurial angle.
So, one of the things I want to do is to just give our
panelists a chance to get a sense for who you are. So, let
me kind of ask you - how many of you are either first or
second year MBA's? Okay. And alumni? Alright, some alumni.
And those of you who are alumni, how many of you are kind of
on the entrepreneurial side of doing ventures? Alright. And
any investors in ventures? Okay. They don't want to put up
their hands probably
[inaudible].
Okay great. So, on our panel we have Andrew, Amy, Jose and
Scott. And I'll let them kind of introduce themselves and
say a little bit about their organizations and their
cultures.
[Inaudible]
You see? See, that's just cause they've never let me teach
the Sloan's. So, Sloan's - any other Sloan's?
[Inaudible]
Okay.
Now, hang on. I just remembered this. Any Ph.D. students?
Any doctorate students? They're locked away in their cubby
holes studying and writing papers which is good. Thank you
for reminding me of that.
[Informal talk].
Alright. So, the agenda is we're going to start and spend
the first part of the conversation talking amongst the
panelists. I've got some questions for them and I'm going to
encourage them to question, and react to one another. And
then the last 30 minutes - basically from 2:15 - 2:45 - we'
ll open it up and you can pepper them with your questions.
Alright. So, just let me say a little bit about the framing
of the topic and the question of building a distinct company
culture. So, the underlying premise is a distinct culture is
important to the success of a new venture and that
successful entrepreneurs are very deliberate about creating
and building a culture that supports their success. There
are strategists who will tell you that in order for a
culture to be a source of competitive advantage it needs to
have three different things.
It's got to be valuable to the organization - a source of
cost saving differentiation and revenue.
It's got to be rare - the unique piece.
I have got to be difficult to imitate or copy. Otherwise
anybody could do it.
So, what I'd like to do is just give the panelists a chance
to start out and just say a little bit about yourself, and
your company, and tell us how would you describe - and how
do people generally describe - the culture of your
organization? And how is that related to its competitive
strategy?
So, I could just go down from the right or is anybody
burning to? I think Scott kind of got nominated by Amy
originally to go first. So, we'll jump around.
Thank you. Cuckolded. I haven't been back in a long time and
get cuckolded. So, my background is primarily as a
technologist. So, I've been a co - founder in three public
companies, two software companies, and one
telecommunications company. And I'm now CEO of a fourth
which is venture funded stealth. And I can tell you that the
big epiphany I had - prior to coming to business school I'd
founded two companies and both companies grew quite large -
hundreds and hundreds of people, different locations.
And one of the experiences I had before I came was I visited
an outlying office that I had. And I remember sitting in a
meeting and about halfway through it all I could think was,
"How did these people get in my company?" What I realized
was that the core group that we had started with was
something that reflected the values of the founders in a big
way. And as the company grew very quickly we lacked the
methodology and the structure so that the culture could
remain consistent as the company grew.
And at that moment when we thought about creating a new
company, one of the things that became very important was
trying to create the culture that I wanted, something that
was durable, and something that was scalable. So, we
actually spent a lot of time in that process of, you know,
trying to come up with something that fit for all the
founders.
And in terms of creating value, it would take too long to
share everything in first blush. But I can tell you the last
company,
[inaudible] which became a public company as well - we had
the lowest turnover in the industry by far in our segment.
Our average salary was at the 50th percentile, you know,
compared to our peers. And you know, the level of
satisfaction, the productivity we got out was really just
great.
So you know, there are very tangible benefits to investing
in culture - some of which you can create, some of which are
basically by virtue of your actions and so forth. But the
net is you're going to get a culture either way. But we
tried to be more premeditated about doing it at
[inaudible].
And if you were to sort of think of the sworn to
characteristics that are really like, "Okay. This is what's
really different about our culture...what stands out?"
Probably the single biggest thing is we became I guess
passionate about feedback while we were here at the GSB - so
touchy, feely. I don't know how many of you are GSB alums
that have taken that. And we all had been in some
bureaucratic environments previously and saw feedback -
institutionalizing it as a method of being able to increase
the velocity of decision making, reduce bureaucracy, and
ultimately resolve issues before they become big.
So, we spent a lot of time implementing a feedback structure
throughout the company and it grew with the company. And
quite frankly, we use it with our new company as well. I
think that was probably the single most impactful tool we
had at addressing issues when they came up immediately and
not letting them fester.
Okay. Amy? Do you want to...?
Sure. My name is Amy Pressman. I'm the Co - Founder and
President of a company called Madelia. We are a technology
company that provides technology that kind of wires really
large organizations to their voice of the customer. So, we
collect feedback, we track social media and we tell the
companies how they're doing.
A couple of things about us - we're bootstrapped. So, we
have not taken a dime of money. We're a little bit smaller
than probably some of the other people here at the table.
But we grew to $25 million so far without taking any money.
And I didn't think about culture at all when we were
started. I think most startups - unless you have really,
really crazy co - founders - probably have pretty good
cultures because just by their nature you've got a bunch of
people that, you know, are totally energized by an idea,
they're coming together. They're in a garage. They want to
change the world, maybe they'll make a lot of money at the
same time.
It's kind of a motivating and empowering thing. And people
tend to have fairly good cultures and then you hear a pretty
typical story that, you know, they meet a lot of milestones
and with each milestone, you know, they'll get more money,
more professionals will come in and somehow the culture isn'
t quite the same as it was back when we were 10 people or
back when we were 50 people.
So, I think we were much the same. We didn't think much
about our culture. We did have similar very low turnover,
very high employee satisfaction scores. We've won awards for
being one of the best workplaces.
But I would say the two things that really, really made me
think about culture are this:
Because we were bootstrapping we didn't have a full fledged
team when we started. So, we ended up hiring a Head of Sales
about five years into our existence and he brought with him
a sales team. And it came all from another company. So, it's
a little bit like a mini - merger. You take the culture of
one company and then you sort of graft it on to our company.
And we did the same thing with our marketing team. We hired
a head of marketing who ended up bringing a bunch of people
from her company.
And it is when you start to see this juxtaposition of these
various cultures that you start to realize, "Oh, this is
what our culture is and this is how it's different from
other cultures.
So, that was, you know, one thing that made me really aware
of it. And I think the other thing is that because of the
product that we have - which is customer experience tracking
- and because we were an unknown startup, we went out and
sold our product to some really well - known brands in the
company. It turned out that one of those were companies that
cared very much about the customer experience and were
willing to take a chance on an unknown startup. And those
tended to be most admired companies.
So, we have this A+ list of customers. We have things like
Apple leading retail, we have Four Seasons and hotels. We've
got companies that care deeply about the customer experience
and we decided that we were going to go out and see what
they did. And we not only looked at these companies at a
company level and at a brand level, we also - because we
track their customer experience scores - went to the highest
performing outlets, for example Gold's Gym - the highest
performing Gold's Gym outlet, the highest performing Hilton
Hotel.
And we sat down and we talked to their General Manager's.
And we started to find a really consistent thing and that is
that they had extremely strong cultures that the management
spent an incredible amount of time nurturing. And what I
realized is all companies have cultures. Whether you decide
to focus on it or not your company will have a culture. When
you spend a lot of time on it and you align the way that you
hire, the way that you train, the way that you fire, the way
that you promote, award, whatever - when you align all that
it becomes an organizing structure.
It's almost in lieu of a lot of levels of management and it
makes you much more nimble because what you're doing is you'
re articulating a culture. You're hiring people that agree
with it and you're able to kind of let them loose. You're
much more productive. You're much more effective.
So anyway, this was based on looking at some of the best
companies and some of the best performing units in those
companies. And they all did the same thing, so it's like "We
want to do that". Especially if we're selling this, we've
got to be able to do it. So, we've spent a lot of time now
trying to immolate them. And I have to say we're not quite
as good as some of our customers, but we're trying hard.
So based on your background, one attribute or quality of
your company - and given what you do - I could imagine it
would analytical. You know, with BCG in your background and
- I almost said Morgan Stanley - Goldman Sachs. So, is that
part of your culture - that you value that kind of political
lens?
And then the other thing I hear you talk about with your
clients is sort of valuing of the high performers or the
elites. Are either of those things that you think are
distinctive about your...?
I think there are a couple of things that are really
distinctive about us. One is we truly, truly do not hire
assholes and we will fire them. Pardon my...I mean, we will
let go of high performers who are corrosive. I mean, I
believe very strongly in the sort of dominance of a team vs.
individual superstars.
I'd say the other one is our mantra is "no mediocrity". No
mediocrity for our customers. We want to help them become
great companies. No mediocrity for our team. So, we're this
interesting mix of super high performance, but a really nice
group of people.
Right.
And so, I think that for the right person that really
resonates. For a lot of people it doesn't and they don't
want to have anything to do with us. But for the right group
of people they feel like, "Well, this is a great place. I
can really strive and yet I feel like everybody's got my
back.:
Yeah. Sounds a lot like the Stanford MBA class. And you
know, I think the faculty certainly are influential in
supporting the nice people...
Right.
that are really, really bright. So, that was a joke that
didn't quite land. Okay. Jose, do you want to?
Sure. Jose Roman. I'm the CEO and Founder of a company
called Jawbone. For those of you that don't know us, we are
- I think according to our friends at Goldman Sachs - now
the largest privately held venture backed electronics
company in the world, very quietly. We're backed by
Sequoyah, Coastal Ventures, and Andreessen-Horowitz.
And you know, we've had a long, interesting ride. I was
actually an undergrad here in the Engineering School back in
the mid '90's when we started the company. We started
working on ideas in '97 - '98 and really formed the company
in '99.
And culture's been an interesting for us because we've had
many sorts of ups and downs to the point where, you know, at
one point in 2005 the doors were actually chained and we
were nearly out of business. And we sort of bounced back
from that and continued to grow.
So, I would say that a big part of our culture has been sort
of this perseverance, total belief in the mission and what
we're trying to accomplish. We like to think of ourselves as
being in the taste business as well. So, design and being
design driven is a huge part of that. So, I'd say it's our
perseverance, design driven and making hard decisions that
often don't feel like they're the exact right financial
decision.
I'll give you guys an example. So, we make things. We make
lots of things in China. And you know, we use medical grade
plastics in all our products. They cost six times more than
a lot of your typical electronics products do. So, to an
Asian manufacturer that is an insane decision, right? They
think we are totally bat shit crazy - sorry for my language.
And it is a fight. And we have to say, "No, you've got to do
this. You've got to do that. Get rid of the draft angles."
And we focus on that. And we ended up winning "Design of the
Decade" from the IDSA for those decisions. And people value
that and it's why we can sell products at higher premiums,
better gross margins. We avoid the commoditization cycle
that you see with a lot of other consumer electronics
products.
So, it all sort of comes together - the sort of perseverance
and fighting for hard decisions, as well as, you know,
staying true to the value, and having great taste
experience, and things like that. So...
Alright. Andrew?
Andrew Hauser. I am currently Founder and CEO of Freedom
Financial Network and Bills.com which are two sister
companies that help people with financial challenges. It
started in 2003 shortly after I graduated from the GSB in
2002 with my friend and Co - Founder, Brad Stroh. And we've
grown from a spare bedroom to about 550 - close to 600
employees today.
And I've been able to watch the evolution of the culture -
the creation of the culture - from the very start. And I
think just listening to your intro, you know, you talked
about what is unique or what is rare. And what's interesting
is thinking about that. There's nothing that's really unique
and rare in theory, right? I could go cut and paste someone'
s mission, vision and values, and put them on my website and
call them my own. And that wouldn't do me a whole lot of
good.
What's unique and rare is living it and believing it. That's
hard. I can take any seven values in the world, but if I
don't believe in them and I don't live them every day, then
that's not really going to do me a whole lot of good. And I
think that's the challenge for any entrepreneur. It's
constant. We talk about constancy, consistency every single
day. You have to be living those values. You have to be
living what you tell your employees you care about. And you
can never be off.
You know, they say a cook is judged by their worst meal. I
like to say, " A leader is judged by their worst
interaction." You know, you walk in every day, and you live
your values, and you say what you need to say about your
customers, about your employees. And then on the 201st day
you walk in and make some offhand comment about your
employees or about your customers, that's the comment people
are going to remember and that one comment can undermine
years of work.
So, we talk about responsibility. We talk about
accountability. We talk about getting good people in the
door, getting bad people out of the door. But if you just
talk about it and you don't actually do it - you don't give
people the responsibility, you don't hold people
accountable, you don't get the - I won't use the word. I'll
be the only person on the panel that doesn't swear in the
intro.
[Informal talk] But if you don't live that, then you don't
have a culture. So...
So, let me ask this question. I mean, I think on this issue
of living it - what are the things - the specific behaviors,
routines - things that you do on a regular basis to
reinforce and to create that culture. I mean, so what does
it actually look like? If we were to follow you around with
a camera for, you know, a month what would be the kinds of
interactions, events, things that really reflect where the
culture is created in your organization? Anybody.
[inaudible] Well, I was thinking about there's informal ways
and there's formal ways. And you know, informally - for
example, we have an office in Phoenix with about 350
employees. I go there once a month for a few days - a week,
a month. And when I walk in I walk around the entire office.
It's now enormous. It's 80,000 square feet. And I say hi to
everyone and try to shake as many hands as I can when I
first walk in.
It seems like a relatively basic thing, but I've gotten so
much feedback - both direct and indirect - on how much it
means to these people to have me walk in and just ask them
how things are going. It takes me, you know, maybe an hour
that first day that I'm in the office - an hour - two hours
- just to walk around to all 350 people, say "hi", say "Good
morning. What's the latest?" Those are informal things.
Informally, just the decisions you make to get rid of
people, the communications you have.
But then there's the formal things. We stole a page out of
Stanford's book. We have brown bag lunches every month where
I get in a room about this size and anyone that wants to
bring their lunch comes by and asks me whatever question
they want.
We have a "Founder's Corner" on the internet. Every day we
update it with news and things that, you know, back up those
values and our vision that we're trying to create. So, both
formally and informally your actions every day and every
week help support that.
I think we're going through a process right now where we're
just over 100 people. We're 110 people and we need to be
much more proactive about our culture. So, what we've done
is we took our corporate vision - which we worked out about
a year ago - and then we worked out all our values. We kind
of refreshed the values with a new crop of people.
And then, we go to each department head and we say, "What is
your department head mission?" And then make sure that that'
s relating to the corporate mission. And then, "What are
your metrics? What does this look like at the end of the
year and how do you know that you've succeeded? Once, you
know, you've hit it out of the ballpark, what is a single?"
And then we meet. In some cases we meet monthly and in some
cases we meet, you know, every quarter and we just see, you
know, "Are you on track?" If you're not on track, "Is there
a problem or do we have the wrong metrics?"
But you're getting everybody to define in really, really
concrete terms what their role is specifically in supporting
that overall mission. And then you are giving them a way to
see how they're doing, and feel accountable for it. And so,
it kind of makes the whole organization come together.
I always find these conversations a little bit theoretical.
So, one of my favorite examples is the best Gold's Gym. And
the Gold's Gym system has to be in the middle of Washington
State. The guy who runs it, you know, their mission is to
make their community - the Wenatchee Valley - the fittest
community in America. And he's given each department, you
know, a role and he says things. To the front desk people he
says, "When you pick up the phone in less than two rings you
are likely helping somebody to be able to play with their
grandchildren in their seventies."
And that takes a very kind of theoretical, you know,
fitness, blah, blah, blah. And it's making it really
concrete. It's making it visual. It's making it a powerful
story and suddenly it's not about answering the phone. Whoa!
It's about helping this person take this first step towards
fitness and playing with their grandchildren.
And a couple of other things he does - I don't know if you
guys know anything about the fitness industry. But some of
their sacred cows are, you know, they want to lock you in.
They want you to pay a high initiation fee. They want to
lock you in with the longest contract possible and they want
to make it really painful for you to get out of that
contract. So, if you move you have to fax in your new
residence papers, or your new lease papers, or your new...
They make it really, really hard. This guy said, "That's
serving our mission of making this the fittest community in
America. No. What would it take for us to get the results
that we need - the retention that we need - without a lockup
and without high initiation fees?" And they got rid of them.
I mean, this is unheard of in the fitness industry. They are
still one of the highest performing gyms. And I think when
you walk in the door of that gym as a customer or as a
prospective customer you feel that these people want to help
you on your journey and they're not just kind of cleaning up
the mission. That is a totally different experience from
your average gym.
So, I mean this is a really concrete example of what it
means to have that culture. And he will fire people. He's
not interested in people necessarily having super toned
bodies, although he himself has one. He wants people that
care very much about other people, convey that and really
buy into that mission. It's extraordinarily powerful. So,
that's just a concrete example that I find very inspiring.
Yeah, I mean I kind of bet that it's pretty hard to get that
attitude in those practices to diffuse throughout the other
Gold's Gyms.
We're working on it.
Yeah.
But yes it is.
See?
You know, it's interesting. In my experience, this is the
only job I've ever had and we interact with all different
kinds of companies - big ones like AT&T and smaller ones
that are application partners of ours and things like that -
startups with five people to
[Inaudible] Telecom which has 250,000 people. And you see
sort of a wide range of cultures.
And I think that the thing that I've realized is that each
culture and each company has to be appropriate for that
company. So, it's really hard to take something that you see
as a best practice somewhere else and try to impose that
into your organization. We do this a lot too. It was
interesting to hear you talk about, you know, lots of people
coming in from the outside. Obviously as you grow and you
scale you hire people who've had jobs at other places. You
can't grow everyone from the internal organization.
So, the first thing I tell all the execs I hired is, "Forget
everything you learned in all those other places." Your
experience is about helping us not make the same mistakes,
but it's a totally new playbook. And let's not even think
about the things that we did in the past. We have to sort of
have the appropriate systems and culture for where we are
today. That doesn't mean that we don't have values that have
sort of permeated us for a long time. And the way you live
it I think changes as the company changes, as the company
grows. As you get international and you have multiple
offices in places you have to do different things all the
way along, and constantly be watching it, and evolving with
it. Do what's appropriate for your organization because it's
not going to be the same for different people depending on
your product, your service, or any of those things. That's
important.
So, I'll give you an example from our past. You know, we
make these headset products and a lot of customers like AT&
T, they make you put your device into their standardized
packaging which reduces a lot of the differentiation you get
or the way you can explain and tell the story around what
you're doing. And it was a huge fight for us because we had
worked it into contracts that we would, you know, get our
own packaging and be able to do our special thing at the
point of sale.
And there was a regime change, you know, merger and things
like that. This was in the Cingular days. They became AT&T
and all those contracts went out the window. And there was a
period of time where we didn't actually have
[inaudible] on the shelf because we refused to sell. It was
our biggest customer and they were trying to impose their
will in terms of making us fit a certain way and do a
certain thing. And we just said, "No, we're not going to do
it. And therefore, we're not going to sell your product on
our shelves." And that was a hard decision. It was our
biggest customer. You can imagine what the venture guys felt
like at a board level. They thought we were crazy.
But we sort of had a long - term view and we said, "You know
what? If you, again, allow this to happen and don't give us
the ability to be true to what our values are and what we
want our brand to stand for, then it's a slippery slope,
alright?" You've got to have people on your team, on your
board that are willing to go with you on that. That's hard.
So, you want to think about, you know, what are the daily
interactions that you have that reinforce or describe the
culture of the company and kind of break it down in two ways
- one is, you know, as an individual, as a CEO - "What
interactions that you have and what are the messages that
you give off? But let me start first with, "What are the
processes? What are the things that we do as a company that
everybody that comes through the company experiences in a
very consistent way?"
So, first off is, you know, we did spend time like everybody
I guess sitting down and deciding, "What are the core values
that describe us - that describe the founders, describe the
company we want to be, describe the relationships we want to
have with our customers?" We spent a lot of time trying to
think about this.
When we started to hire, we tried to convert those core
values into behavioral characteristics that we could use to
select the right people. So, when looking at a group of very
talented people, how do you select the people that
culturally are going to be the best fit for you?
So, one of the things we do is everybody that's in the
company we train in a standard methodology for recruiting.
We use a behavioral interviewing process. Everybody learns
the language, everybody becomes accustomed to it. And every
single person that comes into the company goes through a
rigorous, rigorous recruiting process where, you know,
everybody has a role in the process. It's divvied up across
an entire interview team.
And then, when we finish the process, when we come back to
talk about that particular candidate we do it as a team. And
we literally call it Gun Head. The decision at the end of
the meeting is Gun Head. Do you say hire or do you say not
hire. And it's a unanimous decision.
So, everybody takes responsibility for people that come into
the company because they played a direct role in it. And if
the process is hard, what you find is that even though I may
not know you - you may work in a different office than I do
- if I know that you went through the exact same rigorous
process I feel confident that you're good because you went
through the same filter that I did.
So, once the employees come in, the other thing we talk
about is wanting to be able to evaluate and communicate how
people are doing. So, we're also less so in the phase of
this new startup company, but in the operations Phase and
Fiber Tower, we were very rigorous about defining the PP & D
- the performance evaluation structure we would use for the
people in the company. And some of it was company related
objectives, some of it was personal related objectives. And
most of the personal objectives tied back to the core values
of the company. But we would tie compensation and even more
importantly we would tie equity to the high performers in
the company.
So, one of the processes we used to go through is we would
stack rank employees in the company and we would
disproportionately divvy up equity at the end of every year.
So, my goal was to take 100% of equity and give 80% of it to
the "A" players. And that just reinforced a culture of
people that were trying to exceed their own capabilities,
and then also having a very humane way for people that aren'
t working in the company to exit them out of the company in
a respectful and you know, reasonable process where they
just can't be part of your organization.
And then, you know, things I talked about earlier like
feedback, being able to address issues in a very
straightforward way. Culturally for us that was a big deal.
So, you would often see people leave a meeting where it was
a very simple meeting, but you know, hard decisions need to
be made. And they might grab somebody in the meeting and
say, you know, "I understand what you were trying to do, but
this behavior that you demonstrated was inconsistent with
that goal." And you may not have realized it at the time,
but if you take it in the vein that person is there to help
you be better at what you do, it's a very productive
experience.
And then, I guess finally, I think it's the individual
aspect. "What do you do as an individual in a company?" So,
I guess similar to Andrew we had 14 offices. I used to
travel to every office on a regular circuit. I would go
visit all 14 different offices in different states. And
while I was there I'd try to pick a couple of different
positions there, and I'd spend a day with them. So, if it
was a Field Tech I'd spend a day in the field with them. If
it was, you know, one of our Account Manager's I might go
visit some of the customers. But I wanted to make sure that
I knew every single role in the company and what they did.
And they knew that I knew that. So, when I was talking about
that or when I was experiencing them, you know, in terms of
evaluating them I had a greater feel for it.
And then, the final thing that we did was it's very
difficult at the top of a company to recognize the really
amazing things that happen. And what you find is there are
heroic things that happen every day that never really get
talked about. So, we implemented a sort of an employee based
recognition process we call "Shout Out's" where any employee
in the company could give any other person a recognition
award and that person would get a $50 gift certificate. But
the requirement to do it is they had to draft an email to
the entire company and describe what happened. And we didn't
make that up. We stole that from another company, but...
That's cool.
But it was great because people had the opportunity to hear
- even, you know, at different levels of the company -
amazing and heroic things that were happening.
And then the final thing was creating transparency. And we
tried to over communicate to the company. So, we had a
policy that after every board meeting I would hold a
companywide communication and I would share what was
described. Not all of it was always positive, but at least
they knew exactly where we stood. So, I never viewed my role
as a marketing role to the employees in the company. I
viewed myself as sort of providing the current direction of
what we were doing and what was important for us to be
successful. So, that was
[informal talk].
So, let me just back up on this feedback. And again, one of
the things you're known for is your credibility in the
touchy feely realm of high performance leadership. But I
don't think there's kind of another company here that
wouldn't say, "We really value giving honest and accurate
feedback." But yet it's hard to do. What is it that you
found to be kind of most challenging about really living
consistently that value of being honest and constructive in
providing feedback? I mean, and why is it so rare?
First off, the ironic theme is I'm the only one on the team
that didn't actually take the class. So, I actually took it
through Exec Ed to go figure out what everybody was talking
about.
It's a process that requires continuity. It's a process that
if you do it once it can be very destructive. So, we always
looked at it as a method to be able to. In doing a startup,
you never know if you're going to be successful. You know,
if you look at the odds it's uncanny how many of them
actually fail.
So, we viewed it as a process that even if we did the best
we could and the company didn't work, we wanted to be better
professionals, better individuals, better executives, better
whatever it was and we viewed this as a process for
ourselves. So, in many ways it was very selfish process
because it was a way for us to get feedback from people that
we really respected.
The hardest part was getting people to trust the process.
So, we grew very quickly. We hired people from a lot of
large - ironically - wireless carriers. We had the CTO from
one of the major carriers join us. And we would always give
them a free ride through the first feedback session.
So, I do an executive feedback session and inevitably, I
would talk with them afterwards and they would all go, "That
was really rough! You guys were tough on each other!" And
you know, it was interesting because that was a symptom of
the fact that even though everything that needed to be
discussed was being discussed and it was done in a very
frank - and maybe too efficient - way, he had never
experienced that in where he came from. There was always the
superficial aspect of communication - the 360 evaluation,
the review that comes from the boss - but not something
that's very specific.
So for us, when we did a feedback it was three positives,
three negatives and every single one that you did had to be
backed up by a specific example. You had to say, "In this
situation, you did this and here was the way that I
perceived your behavior." You can't argue with that. The
goal was not to argue with that. The goal was to take that
because that was that person's perspective. You may disagree
with it, but that was what they felt.
So, implementing this was training the people how to do it,
having the continuity that it would happen on a continuous,
repeatable basis, and then building the trust that it wasn't
done, you know, as an offense weapon against somebody. But
the value was for you.
So for example, for us HR never attended the feedback
session. Not a single comment that ever was given in
feedback affected your actual pay or equity in the company.
It was purely for you. So, it was just a way that we
interpreted that particular technique.
Okay. Thanks. So, let me ask Andrew a different question. I
sort of thought about some questions based on the particular
challenges that the organizations might face. How do you
think about or deal with the clash between your company's
culture and how you think about what you're doing, and then
maybe the industry values, philosophy, or culture, right?
So, when Consumer Credit - certainly during a period of time
it was, you know, "Spend. Spend. Spend.", you know, "Borrow.
Borrow. Borrow." And to the extent that you're really trying
to operate differently in that context, how do you protect
your organization from the philosophy in the industry?
That's a very fitting question. Not just Consumer Credit in
general as we all know had some issues over the past several
years, but our industry in particular when we started the
company it was an innovative idea, a way of working out
consumers debts outside of a bankruptcy. We were one of the
few people doing it. We became the industry leader, but it
was a classic
[inaudible] business that resulted in a flood of competitors
especially after all the mortgage people went out of
business. They jumped into our industry.
So, there became a very big disconnect between what we were
saying we were doing for customers, and our core values, and
we belief that we are this white knight here to help our
consumers, and we'll do anything to help our customers and
it's a very emotional, high touch product, and the rest of
the industry - not all of the industry, but certainly what
got picked up in the press. A very, very big disconnect. It
actually - I don't want to go into too many details, but
because we were the industry leader and the industry started
to get a bad name we wound up getting sued by the State of
California.
And so, here we are having built this culture around belief
in our employees, belief in what we're doing, taking care of
customers, helping people through this difficult emotional
point in their life. And all the sudden the State of
California is suing us and saying we're taking advantage of
consumers. You know, that's two pretty big different things.
We're helping consumers through this emotional period. We're
taking advantage of consumers is what the State of
California said.
So, how do we deal with that? It's difficult, but
communication is extraordinarily important. You can't spin
that, right? It's in the news, it's on TV, it's on blogs.
Your competitors are selling against it every day. So, you'
re not spinning it. You're being open, and honest, and you'
re communicating every day, every week. It was an emotional
period for us. But I think, you know, part of it is your
belief which is contagious. True belief in what you're doing
is contagious, right? If people see that you're really
passionate about what you're doing, if you believe in what
you're doing, then they're going to believe it.
And it starts with the founders, but then it goes to, you
know, the next level down. That's really, really important
is getting people in the door early as an entrepreneur.
Those are your ambassadors that are going to carry your
message to the rest of the company. And you know, how do you
get good people as a startup? You know, that's a crucial
question because it's going to pay dividends for tough
events like this. So, communication, consistency, honesty
and then having a really strong management team that truly
believes in what they're doing.
Am I correct in my recollection of the case that it was
written about
[inaudible] is that you actually sort of fought this suit,
you know, longer and harder than some of your advisors that
were like, "Oh, just settle it or let it go." And you didn'
t. You kind of persevered in contesting it?
Yeah, that's correct. There was a case written which some of
you may have read in the new ventures or one of the new
entrepreneurship classes. The key decision at the time was,
"Okay. We have State of California telling us we're doing
all these bad things. We have millions of dollars in
potential litigation expenses coming up. We have the press"
and when the regulator, you know, this is something they
don't teach enough about in business school - especially in
this environment - but regulation is everywhere.
When a regulator decides they're coming after you it's not
just a negotiation. It's they're calling the ABC station,
the NBC station. They're trying to do everything in their
power to sort of press you into a settlement. And so, we
have this, you know, decision to make. Do we just settle
this, pay a lot of money, accept that we did something wrong
and move on or do we fight this, try to deal with the
consequences to employ morale, to public relations, to our
competitors ability to sell against us?
And we ultimately decided to fight. I mean, this is what we'
ve been telling our managers all along. We are not doing
anything wrong. We believe in what we're doing. We're
helping people. Sure, there's knuckleheads in our industry,
but we're doing the right thing and we've ultimately decided
that if we turn around and just agreed, "Okay. We're doing
something wrong. We'll get out of the State of California.
We'll pay all this money in fines" that would send the wrong
message, you know?
And economically it was a tough decision, but in the long
run it certainly was the right decision. Yeah.
Did you win?
We won. I mean, we settled very favorably I would say.
Good for you.
It did not actually go to trial, but the settlement was
extraordinarily favorable. We didn't have to change any
aspect of our business...
Good for you.
which is unusual in a settlement.
That's cool. Okay. Yeah.
Can I say one thing about the feedback?
Sure.
Cause I can't actually stress enough I mean, we've learned
this lesson the hard way because to get through some of the
tough times we had we built deep friendships with people in
the organization. And as you scale quickly some of those
people don't scale with you and yet you're close to them and
their friends. And the thing that I learned the hard way is
that if you don't give people straight, direct, complete
feedback it is much worse than if you thought you could
manage it and sort of package it in a way.
And the thing that we do I think well now that we never did
before - not quite as organized in the way that you guys do
- but we tell people, "Look, this feedback is coming to you
for one reason and one reason only which is that it's to
make you better so that we can exceed as an organization."
It's the only reason you're given feedback because if you're
not given the feedback it means we don't care anymore and
that's a bad problem, right?
So, I think if you start those conversations with that sort
of mindset that the reason we're doing this is it's an
investment and if you don't understand it, it's sort of a
way of working through that. People appreciate that,
alright? Who doesn't want to sort of look in the mirror and
be able to understand? And sometimes folks just don't do it
well.
Right.
So, I think establishing that right up front that it is
about being better and about elevating everyone.
Right. So, let me follow - up on that and actually ask Amy a
question cause you're in the business - in part - of helping
your clients to use feedback from customers to make them
better. And so, how do you influence the culture of your
clients so that they're really using the data in the way
that they should be and not biasing it? And I'll tell a
little anecdote of my experience a number of times with AT&T
which I don't remember whether they're a client or not. So..
.
No.
So, they were clearly getting lots of feedback and I was on
the phone three or four times trying to correct, you know,
some issue. And at the end I always got, "Have I answered
all your questions because you're going to be getting a
survey and I really want you to give me an "A+", or an "H",
or whatever it was, "When they call you for the survey." And
you know, I certainly felt kind of coerced into that. And I
go, you know, "If that's what they're doing is that data
really meaningful?" So, how do you influence the culture in
your clients?
So, we try and share best practices. We host a best
practices conference once a year and bring all of our
clients together. A lot of them get up and give
presentations. And the example that you gave that is
absolutely a worse practice to in any way to try and skew
the results of a survey. And in fact, the case about retail,
you will be fired if you even so much as tell a customer
that they might get a survey. You can't even mention it.
So you know, we try and show that we have this concept of
all companies say they really care about the customer
experience. Maybe 10% really care about it. You know,
another 40% are kind of semi - care about it and then a lot
of them don't really care. It's like motherhood and apple
pie.
So, we have this concept of believers, seekers, and then non
- believers. And I guess our feeling is we try and share the
best practices of the believers - the ones who have shown we
really understand it and some will gravitate. And then, you
know, we really work closely with the seekers to help them
and then at the end of the day we feel better.
If somebody gets, you know, 10% better and they don't become
the absolute best, that's still 10% better. So, I mean we
sort of help people wherever they are on that journey. And
you know, we don't lower our prices. So, we end up heavily
skewed toward the believers because we have the best
product. But the functionality that we have is most
interesting to people who really care about this vs. people
who are paying lip service to it.
Right.
One interesting thing about our product and the topic of
culture is - we were talking about this before this started.
Stories are an incredible part of the culture. The stories
about the founders like you were mentioning one.
But one thing we've found about our customers is there's
always a question that's an open - ended question and you
get these really precious customer comments from time to
time and some of them become, you know, just legend in the
organization.
So, you stop getting just the co - founder's stories or you
know, the superstar employee stories and you start getting
the customer stories. "The customer had this experience."
You hear things for example, about Nordstrom and what
Nordstrom's employees will do for their customers.
And so, we found that our platform ironically does
strengthen culture as those things become almost urban
legends within an organization.
That's great. Okay. So, last question and then we'll open up
for
[inaudible]. So, Jawbone is known for cutting edge - and
this is a quote - "Cutting edge design coming up with
products that people don't know they need, but then they
can't live without." I'm like, "Wow! That's great." I was
like, "I want one of those."
So, this sounds a lot like the culture of innovation,
engineering, you know, design being ahead of customers. But
it seems like there are a lot of stories of the danger with
that kind of culture is that you can become ancillary and
insensitive to customers. And it's kind of like, you know, "
Well, we know best." You know, "You'll know what you want
when we tell you what it is." And then you sort of lose your
market.
How do you either balance that, protect against that
possibility and think about, you know, "We want to listen,
but we also want to push
[inaudible]
That's a great question. I think that's an existential
challenge for a company like us, right? Because so much of
what we do - especially as we push into new categories and
new markets - you're looking around a corner and you're
trying to guess what people want.
So, we do. It's on multiple different vectors. It's also in
terms of how do we manage our investment against those new
things and sort of take it step by step, and phase. Test
something, see if it works. Go behind. It's a little bit of
what we call a chasing model. So, if it's working really
well we double down and push into it. So, those are kind of
just financial risk things that we do.
But you know, fundamentally I think that what we try to do -
and this is sort of the way we build products actually - is
we make a map and we don't do MRD's, or PRD's, or any of
those things. We don't do focus groups. We don't do any of
it.
We basically sit around - and there's a core group of about
six people in the company who work on this - and we make a
map of, "So, here's the way that the world works today with
all the kinds of devices that we interact in." We're the
friction points in the way that we use these devices or
other people. Now you can get a lot of data from customers
and many people around. What are the friction points? Where
are the things that don't work? You know, would they have to
push a button here, take that thing out or whatever?
And then we start to say, "Okay. Well, if we could solve
that problem and innovate, you know, 'Do we need to push the
Silicon guys or do we need to build networking technology
and support?'" And then we start to push on all those
different threads. And then we build stuff say, "How are we
resolving against this experience continuum?" And
ultimately, it's about making and using technology to make
things easier for people or allow them to communicate in
places they didn't before, and things like that.
And so, that's one of the issues from the product
perspective we try to resolve when we say, "It's about
making things easier and resolving experiences. Wouldn't it
be great if you could do this right here?"
So, it is a little bit Star Treky with
[inaudible] and some of that stuff. But I think you're going
to make some mistakes for sure and it's how you structure
yourself to reiterate quickly...
Right. And be able to recover from that.
Yeah, and be able to recover. And you know, that's one of
the reasons we almost died a few times and it just changes.
So, we have this sort of multi - headed system intact.
Can I add something on that?
Yeah.
Cause our customer sees it two ways. There are two big
components. One is service and one is product. And on the
service side, a lot of our companies, they have strong
cultures so they delegate a lot of responsibility to their
front lines and they don't micromanage. Some franchise
organizations you'll go into and you'll feel like you're
getting the scripted, "Did you find everything you need?"
But others you actually have a real conversation. So, we
tend to serve those groups. And what happens is different
people try different things, you know, at different stores,
or different banks, or whatever it is. And then our system
you start to see customer satisfaction...
Right.
is spiking, customer satisfaction is dropping. What's going
on here? It turns out this manager came up with a really
innovative solution to a problem. I've got a great example.
I'm going to try and camouflage who it is, but basically
customer satisfaction across this company tanked. Then one
guy looked at it and he realized that "salesperson" and "
rude" kept coming up with the low scores for a particular
product. So, he asked the salespeople. And they said, "Yeah,
it's off warranty and everybody's really pissed off when
they find out it's off warranty."
So, he told them when they all came to work this next day -
they all owned this particular product themselves. He took
it from them for a day and he gave it back 24 hours later
and customer satisfaction in that store spiked because now
people came in with this product off warranty and all of the
sales reps that they ran into said, "That sucks! That
happened to me the other day. I am so sorry! Bad news is,
you know, it's off warranty. The good news is I can..."
And it was the same message...
Right.
delivered with genuine empathy and that was it. And it was
like a brilliant, smart
[inaudible]. And then somebody at corporate saw this spike,
went in and found out what it was, told the rest of the
organization, scores went up everywhere.
So you know, that's on the service side. On the product
side...
It's a lot of listening.
Yeah.
You've got to listen carefully.
But it's also allowing people who are in the front lines...
Right.
communicating with the marketplace to use their judgment to
deal with the nuance. And on the product side, Hyatt is one
of our customers and they started a new concept, "Hyatt
Place" for the thirty - something business travelers. And
they did a whole bunch of focus groups to get rid of things
like the front desk, and all these things that are sort of
standard in hotels. And then they put it out there with us
and they were just monitoring. They had a couple of hotels
and they were trying, you know, "Should we serve this kind
of food or that kind of food?" in terms of the product side
and just really, really tracking it and being very
innovative, and quickly changing if it wasn't working.. And
so just being very, very nimble and not expecting to get it
100% right when they rolled it out.
So you know, I think it comes down to the ways to get that
listening and feedback.
Right.
[Informal talk] I'm watching time. I probably should have
kind of punctuated this point and come to the sort of
closing part a little earlier. But is there anything - any
insights about culture or startups - that, you know, remain
unsaid that you would just be not satisfied if you didn't
leave this group with that last pearl?
So, we've got about five minutes.
Yeah.
Anything
[Overlapping]
maybe potentially a little controversial, but what I have
learned is the value of the team vs. the value of
individuals. And at the end of the day if you're like me,
and you've gone to great schools, and you've gone to
business school, and you've worked in certain organizations
- unless you've played a team sport you know nothing about
teamwork really. You probably think you're doing teamwork
when you all huddle together, divide up tasks, run off, do
your tasks, come back together. That's not teamwork.
So, I think that we hire a lot of people just like me in our
company. And so, we're all learning to be better true team
players and I think a book that was really influential for
me is called "Tribal Leadership". It's by a professor out of
USC and he looked at all these different organizations, and
listened to the language that they had, and he divided
cultures into five different cultures. I won't bore you with
it, but it really talks at the end of the day about when you
have true teamwork you get to a stage where you're not
really going to have these interdepartmental conflicts cause
everybody is going to be working toward that same goal.
And he finds that in only about 20% of companies. And the
vast majority are all in a level where it's all about, "I'm
great, others not so much." Sorry about that. You know, the
ingoing assumption is, "Don't' trust until they earn your
trust" rather than "Trust until they don't earn your trust."
The ingoing assumption is to withhold information rather
than to share information. It's a great way read and if you
read it will probably resonate with you in different places
that you've worked.
And so, that really made me think about how little I
understood about true teamwork and how many of the people
around me didn't really understand it either. So..
I guess the way I would leave it is, you know, when we talk
about good culture it's a very enormous concept. What's good
for me may be different for Andrew, may be different based
on different organizations, different requirements and so
forth. But what I always find interesting - particularly
when you're interviewing people - is people can't always
describe what the perfect culture is, but they can very
clearly tell you what bad cultures they've been part of.
So you know, what are the behaviors? It could be the 201st
experience they had with an executive that was completely
out of character with, you know, what a company says. But
you know, it's a matter of feeling what's right for you at
that moment in time, what's right for the employees who are
there. But so much of good culture is just common sense.
There are just certain things that you don't do. You treat
people respectfully. You know, you have to empower them. You
have to allow them to make decisions. As long as there's a
core baseline of values that you subscribe to, everything
else you put on top is okay. Just the bad stuff is
universal.
Okay. So, I think a lot has already been said. I would say
that for some of you that are considering entrepreneurship
especially a lot of you that have worked for whether it's
private equity banking, consulting you haven't really had to
think of this developing of the culture.
One thing to think about as a founder and entrepreneur is
your visibility. It's extraordinarily powerful and more so
than you can even imagine. There is, you know, a magnifying
glass on everything you do, everything you say.
Good and bad.
Good and bad. And a lot of people talked about feedback.
Feedback's extraordinarily important. You've got to be
careful about doing it in public. Anything that you say -
some small, constructive feedback - is magnified 10 times by
the person that's receiving it just because of your role as
the founder in the company. That's a hard thing to adjust to
when you're out of business school that, "Wow! These people
are hanging on my every word." If I come in the office and I
look stressed out, that stresses other people out. If I come
in the office and I'm happy that makes other people happy.
It's a very surreal experience when you start to realize how
visible you are and how much people are looking at your
every action, and every action that you take is creating
that culture.
Last word.
I totally agree with that. And I mean, it's a constant
evolution in learning because that visibility and that sort
of how people hang on what you say is changing all the time.
It's different and different people react to things
differently. I would totally agree with that.
The thing I would say to take away that probably people won'
t tell you about culture is that it's very, very dynamic,
right? And there are core values that Scott talks about that
are just fundamental things that you've got to decide what
you want to do and those things will be part of the
character forever.
But in terms of the systems, and incentives, and rewards,
all that stuff changes a lot. And you know, I think you've
got to be prepared for that reiteration cycle especially in
the entrepreneurial world. It's okay. It's okay and I would
say to always remember to take a little bit of a longer term
view than feels necessarily comfortable.
Okay. On that note, please join me in thanking our panel.
And...